[Music]
here are 20 first step decluttering
ideas to help you get started
number one
declutter the inside of your car
that's a great first step because quite
often i mean you can't have too much of
a horde in your car although there are
some people we certainly see yeah and
we'll jokingly see like it's full the
whole back seat is full and the
passenger seat is full and
and it's like oh wow like there's a
whole it feels like they've brought
their whole house with them right like
they're living out of their car yeah but
it'd be way harder to live out of a car
without much stuff in it right and so
but the average person just has a bunch
of extra stuff that we're keeping in
there why just in case
and so starting with the car oh it's so
freeing when you declutter your car we
don't have any excess in your car so i
totally agree with joshua becker and
what he's saying here in this article
your car is a great place to start yeah
number two
clear off your bathroom counter
man flat surfaces
this is where clutter often
accumulates because it's so easy here
i'll just set this here for a moment
yeah it's so enticing oh yes
oh look at that all that wide open space
on the bathroom counter
and then all before we know it's makeup
it's lotions it's creams it's cleansers
it's soap it's
toothpaste all of these things that are
just piled up there now the key isn't to
simply pile it all into a drawer yeah
but clear it off letting go of the
things that you're not using anymore and
then yes storing the things that you do
use regularly now you can use our 90 90
rule for that
you can download all of our rules in the
minimalist rule book by the way the
minimalists.com
rulebook 16 rules for living with less
we have the justin case rule now we have
the 90 90 rule have i used in the last
90 days
if not will i use it in the next 90 days
that's a great rule especially for your
bathroom counter oh yeah it makes me
think about uh
like my shower before i really started
doing the whole minimalist thing i just
you know you try a product it kind of
works you know a face wash or a shampoo
or conditioner
and like it sits in the shower and then
you're like okay that didn't work too
well i'm gonna go get something else but
you still leave the one that didn't work
in the shower just in case just in case
and it's funny because uh
yeah like i really simplified you know
the things that were my [ __ ] now it's
like soap shampoo conditioner like
that's it one soap one shampoo one
conditioner
and uh when mariah and i moved in
together um we uh yeah we like just
simplified it to where um yeah she was
like wow this is so much easier to like
take a shower without worrying about
knocking over stuff i'm like yeah i know
right i i so much prefer that when
you're able to combine
things obviously if you're living with
someone they're going to have things
that work well for them right you're
going to have and so brian and i have
completely different face tone so we use
different lipsticks
yes and so
what's nice though is you can do this
together you can clear the counter
together because the thing to not do is
like i'll just throw away all of
mariah's stuff here look half of the
stuff's already gone right yeah so doing
it together allows you to grab their
buy-in as well the third thing on this
list from joshua becker is remove 10
items from your wardrobe
i call this shopping for clothes in your
closet
or it's like reverse shopping well
because here's what happens is like we
caught off and hold on to things like i
i'm wearing that i bought it because it
looked good on a mannequin but i know
like i try it on and it's a little too
big or a little too small a little too
awkward or a little too orange
and i'm holding on to this thing for
some hypothetical use in the future and
so i'll try it on
oh yeah you know what i don't like this
i don't think i would buy it and if that
was a key oh i don't think i'd buy this
that's the sign that i want to let it go
yeah so would i re-buy this thing in my
closet if the answer is no
let it go ooh that rhyme danny
number four
declutter the visible areas of your
entertainment center
or just get rid of your entertainment
center right get rid of your
entertainment
entertainment there was this 2007.
dude that is funny man i can't think of
the last time i even let yeah
i've seen an entertainment center i'm
just kidding i have a credenza which is
a fancy way of saying i mean you you've
been to my house a few times yeah for
sure i do credenza oh yeah yeah yeah
we're like we're the bowls sitting on
top of and stuff yeah yeah so i guess
that's my entertainment center there's
some books on top of it there's a piece
of art on top of it there's a few va
vases is it vaz is 14 inches or higher i
don't know depends on how pretentious
you are really
well then they're definitely bosses
number five i think this is an important
one clear off your nightstand
nightstand clutter oh yeah is there it's
like it's so there's a feng shui element
to this right dude but i used to use a
cajon the cajon that you gave me i used
to use that as my nightstand which is
like a drum that you sit on right yeah
it's like a box basically yeah drum box
you could think of it uh so
we
we had mismatching um night stands so we
just happened to like be driving by
there was a garage sale like saw the
nightstands out of the corner of my eye
i was like oh like we've been looking
for some nightstand so we got them but
they have drawers in them
and now it's like now i now i just have
extra storage for things
i mean i didn't i don't have them all
filled up but i just noticed myself like
i'll just throw that in the nice thing
i'm just like i now have you know uh
nightstand junk drawers basically you
wouldn't buy at two accidental junk
drawers right yeah so yes you can clear
the nightstand
but don't simply clear it into the
drawer by clearing it it's selling
donating recycling trashing etc i've
been doing it wrong number six
walk around your home and fill one box
with items to donate we'll do this with
ella quite frequently and because she'll
have toys that she's no longer finding
value in
she lets them go and she understands by
letting them go she's actually making
room for new toys yeah and if she
understands that as a kid
we can understand that as adults as well
or we're also making room for more
experiences more space more peace more
calm
and so one donation box and having the
whole family do it you can do it in five
minutes and all of a sudden you're
getting started on the letting go dude i
went and visited uh mariah and i went
and visited uh bexanella when we were in
missoula just a couple weeks ago
and uh ella wanted to play operation and
half of the pieces were missing and it
was driving me crazy
but she really had a good time and i
learned a lesson
about about um you know not being ocd
when it comes to playing operation
well let's read a few more of these 20
and we'll put a link to the article in
the show notes on patreon here
all right number six we already did that
number seven walk around your home and
fill one bag for trash pickup this is
the unfortunate truth
we are holding on
to a bunch of trash in our homes yeah
now if it can be recycled great but as
we know we're not that efficient with
recycling nine percent of the plastic
bottles that we recycle actually get
recycled and the same is true with many
of our things and so we feel bad so what
do we do we cling to it now it's making
us miserable and it's not getting
recycled yeah and so yes throwing it
away
is a last resort but sometimes we have
to resort to that last resort when we
have no other options so we can move on
it's in our lives it's interesting i
remember we went to a this was in new
york we were filming
someone who was like a minimalist but
they were also zero waste
and they were talking about how they had
like this one tub
of like uh you know
bad light bulbs or like stuff they
didn't know how to get rid of yeah so
they just like held on to it
and uh yeah i just i think i was just
like encouraging this person like hey
sometimes you have to throw some things
away it's okay and yeah by the way bravo
for living the life you live right but
it's either trash in your closet or
trash in the landfill and at least in
the landfill it would decompose faster
than sitting in your closet that's right
yeah unless you misunderstand compost
piles like me
i just dropped an apple on the floor
three minutes ago yeah that was uh
it's already gone so like all right so
yeah so josh
um you know back in back in the day like
year i don't know
in our mid-20s
uh you know there would be like a gum
wrapper and and josh would like fling it
and i'm like dude what are you doing
like you can't litter and he's like i'm
starting a compost pile
but then it became a joke like on tour
yeah obviously i don't do any of that
stuff now no yeah we would be on tour
and like we'd be on an elevator i'd
finish eating an apple i just throw it
on the floor in the elevator what are
you doing i'll just calm down
don't worry about helping the
environment
and by the way it was never more than a
gum wrapper like you were not you were
not a litter bug at all it was just like
a little yeah anyway
number eight remove old or expired food
from your pantry and fridge we did a
whole episode on expired items you can
go back and listen to that but i was
surprised by and even as a minimalist
how many expired items now not all
expired items are actually expired so go
back and listen to that whole episode we
talk about the nuances there and we read
some definitions that i think are pretty
important to understanding what is truly
expired and what is marketing hype
number nine declutter old or unused
coats and items from your coat closet
never
[Laughter]
you little jacket [ __ ] you
my wife calls me a jacket so i have six
jackets and it's the one area that i am
not super minimalist although i wear
them all the time so in one regard you
would say okay you get value from those
they all fall within the 90-90 rule for
me the seasonality rule right
and i've certainly worn all of them and
anytime where i don't wear them i
promptly let go of them yeah but could i
get by with one jacket or one jacket one
coat yeah for sure but i like having
that uh some variety on the top layer
because i'm wearing the same shirt and
pants
almost every single day basically yeah
number ten clear off the top of your
refrigerator and this is especially
helpful for really tall people like me
i'm of the height where i see i go to
everyone's house and i see
everything that's on top of their fridge
and it's it's always full of dust
and some it always drives me crazy at my
house when it's full of dust other
people's houses they don't drive me
crazy but i i see it and i'm like oh
they don't that's funny like just if
you're two or three inches shorter than
me right you don't see the dust on top
of the the fridge and
quite often people will pile other
things on top of their fridge as well i
don't know why but like i remember
growing up my mom had it was like all
these cookbooks
that she'd never used i was like oh
there's cookbooks on top of the fridge
yeah and dust
cookbook is collecting dust yeah right
ooh there's like a a blog post titled
there or something let's see if we can
do a lightning round with the last 10.
recycle old magazines or newspapers that
are left piled up yes guess what
you are not going to go back and read
the
third quarter details magazine from 2012
yeah
if you need time to let it go yeah and
if you need to it's online yes indeed
yeah number 12 declutter your underwear
and or sock drawer i think he means
underwear drawer or sock drawer
but you can declutter your underwear too
yeah go commando it's the only way to be
a real minimalist number 13 clear five
items from your kitchen counter clear
all the items from your kitchen counter
we just did an episode about kitchen
clutter with max lugavir i think you'll
enjoy that episode you can go back and
listen to the entire kitchen clutter
episode number 14 remove excess towels
and linens from your linen closet that
reminds me of when i was dealing with my
mom's stuff it looked like someone was
running a hotel out of her linen closet
with all the mismatched bath towels and
dish towels and beach towels and bed
sheets and blankets and quilts she had a
lot of stuff in that closet
some of which she used yeah you could
tell because it was the stuff that was
reused over and over again that was on
top
and all the other things that smelled a
bit musty underneath
if it smells musty maybe that's a sign
that you can let it go
number 15 declutter your laundry space i
have a shared laundry room in my
building so i don't have a laundry space
which makes it easy for me to keep
free right
sharing the sharing economy leads to a
more clutter-free life quite often
because you don't have to own all of the
things yeah number 16 clear off the tops
of your living room side tables or don't
have side tables that's another way to
do it we do this every night when we set
the stage at night we've talked about
this in the past but we set the stage
we'll spend five minutes or so clearing
off any flat surfaces that may have
accumulated something throughout the day
whether it was mail or books or remote
controls or papers or toys we clear it
out the end of the night so we wake up
the next morning to a calm clean
clutter-free house
a few more here number 17 minimize your
tupperware
yeah or don't use tupperware because it
leaches plastic into your foods
we talked about that during the kitchen
clutter episode number 18 declutter your
shower keeping only what is essential
you talked about that already ryan
number 19 clear out your medicine chest
again finding expired medications
because that is one thing with
medications if they are expired it's not
that they are expired so much as they
tend to lose their potency many
medications do after their expiration
date but that depends on the medication
as well so go back and listen to that
expired items podcast episode remember
wolf of wall street when they took the
expired quaaludes
that could happen with your tylenol even
good really
and number 20 return toys to the toy
room toy room
becker's such a minimalist
my toy room's right next to my war room
[Laughter]
return toys to the toy room or bedroom
where they belong yeah each night ella
helps with the
with the setting the stage and there are
some bins that her toys go back into
they don't belong on the floor or on the
counters or anywhere else they belong in
their homes which are their toy bins you
can check out that full article from
joshua becker at becomingminimalist.com
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free